I used to spend a lot of time reading I
don't know if that surprises you quite
enjoy reading fiction nonfiction but um
ever since like as you go through life
stages I don't know if this is
concerning to you and you're like man
eat 12 I feel like I've got no time for
anything like year 11 was sorry cruzi
what was I worried about you tab I Got
News for you that's sensational Oh in
the past was nothing now life is you
know Crampton lots of stuff that keeps
going so you get to university and
you're like what life is so cool what
was I worried about in 12 but then and
then you get to full-time working you're
like what would those lazy uni but knew
my sister that's worrying about and then
you have children you know like one of
those childless people were in a night
so so I don't read so much as I used to
so I listen to a lot of podcasts and
audiobooks were cut which are kind of
the time poor person's version of
reading and my favorite podcast it
always starts its own each podcast
Answer what they call follow up which is
you know what what's left over from
unresolved issues from last time you can
wear boys come in take you soon so I'm
gonna start with follow up today and
there are two questions that we sort of
raised yesterday which we're not
entirely resolved so we're gonna sort of
address them and then get on to calculus
okay now the first question actually
some of you also took a small number of
you your answer to me and I answered it
but I realized Sun reflection later that
the sort of the answer I gave would be
useful to more than the five or six
people who heard the answer okay so I'm
going to recite it for the rest of you
and those of you who actually did here
yesterday you can just sit back and
relax now remind me if you could
describe this this graph right which is
what we spend our time on yesterday if
you could to describe any words express
the kind of shape and behavior that it
exhibits
it's an odd function good so we've got
some symmetry there okay but I don't
know what kind of shapes are reflect so
I don't know what to draw yet how else
can we describe it it's very similar to
saw the shapes you already know hmm
it's it's Lydia kind of its kind of
linear it's made up of straight lines
okay what kinds of where do the straight
lines go like do they go up and down or
cross or how would you describe them I
think I think we said is periodic right
it's very similar to what regular sign
looks like if you turned it into a
linear fashion right so that's why you
get this kind of shape it's not
functioning okay now one of the
questions that are somewhat very
astutely asked was oh hold on a second
sigh averse side universe just taken on
its own side of us has a restricted
domain okay it only exists for certain
values of X and it doesn't exist lots of
those events right so how is it that if
this thing is restricted this thing the
whole thing is not restricted because as
you see it goes forever okay how does
that work apart from just plugging in
values which will get which should show
that to you right how can we analyze
this and work out what's going on okay
so here's an illustration for you to try
and help you understand why this thing
is for values but while this does not
okay let's go back to what we understood
about functions right I said a function
is all about taking the inputs right and
then we define the function of some kind
of rule right would you tell you what to
do with those inputs in some reliable
way and then it spits out an output yeah
that's what we mean by a function okay
now to add on to that and try and extend
the metaphor right domain and range
they made a range which we've been
talking about all this time restrictions
where would they fit on this diagram how
do they change or give us more
information about this weather snow gram
is telling us right
well domain arranged which will in
corresponds to outputs in which one car
suppose two inputs ranges outputs right
so these are kind of like Y values and
these are kind of like X values right so
therefore you've got your domain
affecting your inputs and your range
affecting your appellants okay now let's
be a little more specific what does the
domain tell you about the inputs what
kind of information is that provided to
you but that we didn't have before if we
understand what domain is now in terms
of like a graph right you would say
domain is all of the X values where the
function exists right that's a
reasonable definition domain is where
the functions exist where I can draw it
okay where you can stick a value to
calculator and get something meaningful
out okay but another way of thinking
about it is domain is the kinds of
inputs right the kinds of inputs that
this function will acept I said again
it's very important so nate is the kinds
of inputs functions going to accept now
we know lots and lots of different kinds
of functions right some functions are
are very broad and they'll take anything
right so lots of the ways we start off
money functions like this right anything
which is a polynomial right what are the
domain of these what was the original
question what x-values do these
functions exist for not a rhetoric
question for real values right in other
words their domain right the kinds of
inputs they accept is they'll take
anything don't take anything okay
so I'm kind of doing functions right a
little bit like children
yeah children I've got a three euro now
he's right at this point okay
I'm children can be very fussy eaters
and maybe you're like I'm still fussy
they don't want to eat certain foods
don't really take particular kinds of
foods and if it doesn't meet those kinds
of criteria right I only eat blue foods
this week then they won't touch it okay
yeah well the other hand you've got
functions like this children maybe you
know some of these who they're just like
you put anything in front of them and if
it's like you know even if it's not
meant to be edible they later so so my
son is nine months old you're just like
crawl around the floor and you'd be like
you know this looks this looks like it
fits in my hand let's keep it a guy
right so not very fussy right so some
functions they need everything their
domain is all real values okay but some
are fussy can you give me some examples
of fussy functions you could say the
square root of x that's not a polynomial
is it right what will it eat what's its
domain give me something greater than or
equal to zero and I'll take it
it was negative forget it okay I'm not
touching that stuff with a ten-foot pole
okay do me another one which is a fuzzy
function right almost the same domain
but it's a little more fussy isn't it it
won't take zero okay and we've already
noticed this guy now how does he break
on the scale of fussiness the answer is
pretty fussy debate what will you set
negative one to one and that's it full
stop very very limited range okay so
that's what it's really interest at
right now you can see what's going on
here I went I won't draw out the
argument these are the kinds of things
which should or output and will only
output certain things right of course
you've got some functions which will
I'll put anything right or real values
of Y then you got again you've got other
functions right and they're a little
more well they're fussy on the other end
of things right what kinds of values
will this put up greater than or equal
to zero right because that's the that's
the range of x squared okay
now I think we have enough pieces now
we've established
now if we make this same inverse of that
if that's our function right we can only
take some kinds of inputs and
correspondingly it will only give you
some kinds of outputs specifically
between negative fun to the planets you
that's okay
so if it's fussy that's a problem that's
why it's restricted that's why it does
it exists everywhere so now can you see
why is it that this thing when we take
this this is not going to be fussy
anymore what has it done okay
well let's think about this dance that
was so much let's consider different
functions sine the inside function right
it's sort of fussy II know it's not is
it
it'll take anything right it's that um
it's that garbage bin of your friend
who's like you know these leftovers that
know what C I'll take it you know
weights not what not so he'll take
everything right
so I next exists for all real values aha
but what's the range of sine
it's from negative one to one the range
the outputs sorry that's what I'm into
right yep it's a very specific there
always that's why they're always in
there always that's all we talked about
amplitude in that kind of thing so now
if I take this guy right the inputs to
come in and these are the outputs it
producers and if I put him over here
okay because that's what this is doing
right you take a value when you stick it
in cafe first you do sign and then you
decide sine inverse of whatever you end
up with right well he'll take anything
he's not fussy he'll take it all okay
but then what he gives only between
negative 1 and 1 right which is exactly
what sine inverse wants it will always
give you something which sine inverse is
willing to eat so if you like science
kind of like oh he's a really good chef
you know there's mystery box challenges
and you're like in you get all this
random assortment but he's so good he
can always come up with something but
even a fussy eater will always eat does
that kind of make sense so something
which usually will only take certain
values it suddenly now exists all the
time because of what's happening here
all values then it gets restricted on
the range end and then when this guy
takes him takes it he's happy that kind
of makes sense so think about functions
and what they're willing to eat and what
they're what they're really to produce
ok and that's how you get that's how you
resolve mysteries like this